Jason asks what's the hardest thing
you've had to deal with in the past five
years and how did you get through it
Jason over the last five years the
hardest thing that I've had to deal with
you know hands down it has to be the
fact of siphoning off of wine library TV
daily grape that routine of six years
and really leaving the day in day out
operations of the family business that
is the most emotional business you know
working with my dad kind of this
transition of being day in and day out
with my dad to being day in and day with
my brother enormous emotion comes with
that yeah I probably never even realized
that that would ever happen it was a
very big brain twist for me that I would
be transitioning out of the family
business into another chapter in my life
and I struggled with that quite a bit a
lot of heavy emotion the the
relationships and people at Wine Library
my dad and I dynamics just all these
very interesting things there was also
happening right when Misha was born it
was an interesting time in my life I was
was growing up and and transitioning and
changing I dealt with it with what I
deal with everything and really probably
the cornerstone of my happiness I dealt
with it by over communicating the the
level of communication I had with the
people involved was very high and and
allowed for it to happen and so that's
what I did